[Music]  the cradle of humankind region  is truly remarkable right  on the edge of johannesburg is a  tremendous pristine wilderness  that is startling and spectacular which  holds these hidden treasures right on  its doorstep  there's hundreds if not thousands of  caves many of which contain  fossils that are telling us the story  of us  [Music]  there is nowhere else in the world where  you can have the potential of witnessing  the discovery of one of the rarest  objects on the planet  a fossil of a human ancestor  when i first bring people to the cradle  of humankind and they begin to  understand  the story of human origins they suddenly  realize that their ancestry is from  right here that they're home  that's humbling  you